تملك روسيا اكبر احتياطي للغاز في العالم
بنحو
19.9% وانتجت في عام 2020 نحو
مليار متر مكعب صدرت منها
10 مليار متر مكعب وبرزت روسيا في عام
كاكبر مورد للغاز الطبيعي الى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
[موسيقى]
تنطلق شبكه امدادات الغاز من روسيا الى
اوروبا عبر مجموعه من الخطوط تمر اربعه
منها عبر اوكرانيا وتشكل هذه الخطوط اكبر
ممر لنقل الغاز الروسي بسعه تصميميه تقترب
من مئه مليار متر مكعب سنويا
استحوذت عمليه نقل الغاز عبر اوكرانيا على
26% من الغاز المرسل من روسيا ويبلغ معدل
رسوم عبور الغاز الروسي لاوكرانيا دولارين
و66
مقابل كل مليون متر مكعب لكل 100 كم وهي
التكلفه الاعلى اوروبيا
بطبيعه الحال قررت روسيا تنويع طرق توصيل
الغاز لذلك ولدت فكره بناء خطوط الغاز
بدون دول عبور والتي تصل مباشره الى السوق
الاوروبيه
كانت الفكره هي وقف ارسال الغاز عبر
الطريق البري لاخراج اوكرانيا من المعادله
كطريقه لمعاقبتها والانتقال مباشره الى
المانيا لتصبح اول ميناء لوصول الغاز
يمتد خط نورد ستريم واحد المزدوج بطول
1224 كيلو مترا عبر بحر البلطيق من روسيا
الى المانيا ولديه القدره على نقل 55
مليار متر مكعب من الغاز سنويا الى دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي يوازيه النردستريم 2
والذي يستطيع النقل 55 مليار متر مكعب
اضافي الا ان المانيا اعلنت ايقاف البدء
بنقل الغاز عبر نورد ستريم 2 بعد اندلاع
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
اما خط يمان فقد اوقفت روسيا ضخ الغاز فيه
منذ عام 2021
وكان ينقل الغاز عبر بيلاروسيا بطول اربعه
الاف ومائه وسبعه كيلو متر وقدره
استيعابيه 33 مليار متر مكعب في السنه
واخيرا خط التورك ستريم والذي يبلغ طوله
930 كيلو مترا ويمتد عبر البحر الاسود
وينقل احدى وثلاثين وخمسه من عشره مليار
متر مكعب من الغاز سنويا الى تركيا وجنوب
شرق اوروبا